oh it's ringing
what are you doing no that's not a new
one
hi is this Mark Normand
no is Mark there
Mark Normand no
wrong number
wrong number oh this is uh who is this I
this is Howie Mandel
hello my name is Liz Williams I'm Mark
Norman's mother oh oh hey mom so I'm I'm
Howie Mandel and I'm doing a podcast
with uh with uh my uh another Mark
Normand do you know if your son has the
does he have marknorman.com did he hold
that website
I thought it was Martin
mormoncomedy.com it is but we're trying
to buy markets Mom oh is this is your
mom yes
oh
you little rascal see what I did I
brought back the Rascal yes oh this is
your mother yeah why didn't you want to
give it how did I get your mother's
number I don't know sorry Mom we're
trying to buy a domain site here we're
calling all the people with my name I
mean you came up in the list I'm here
with with uh your little queef
um are you proud of him because I am
yes of course he's on the podcast right
now
great
is that woman I gotta tell you that I'm
a huge fan of your son and I'm a huge
fan of what he's doing and you should be
very proud
I wasn't worried I was trying to get him
his own I don't understand what happened
I just got confused and now it's like a
parent-teacher conference
have you when's the last time you saw
him live in concert you have to go see
him live in concert the last time I saw
him live was when he was performing in
New Orleans right like a year ago and do
you sit in the back of the room going oh
my god this is my son and these people
just are laughing and enjoying and
drinking in what me and my husband
created
well yeah I mean I'm I'm very proud of
him I I think and I actually think he's
funny so
you sound more surprised than anybody
you know I actually think this young man
is funny he is yes no no I'm not
pretending that I think he's funny I
really do think he's funny well that's
great well we we love that you made this
for us for the world uh geez okay
what I'm doing right here is I'm trying
to add I'm trying to add I think we
needed two more minutes of sincerity to
close this uh podcast is there anything
you'd like to add Mrs Normand what's
your name my name is Liz Williams Liz
Williams yes
um I
I don't have anything well if you have
nothing to say then I'd like to ask you
to sing a song pardon me can you just
sing a little something for us and we'll
use this as the closing number of the
podcast just sing something
how about Mary had a little one that's
that'd be great that would really work
go ahead Mark Norman will go to Mark
Norman comedy wait wait hang on to Mark
Norman
[Music]
screaming
keep going keep going keep going one
more time yeah keep singing
um
[Music]
this has been Howie Mandel does stuff
[Laughter]